[Musique]
il
au lieu de faire un pas qu on fait ce
qu'on appelle les a et la vente la
beauce et là à partir de l'âge de 16 ans
les élèves peuvent choisir seulement
trois matières pour pouvoir excéder
accéder aux universités et non seulement
au royaume uni mais partout glande
s'écrire un peu de l'égalité chez tous
les élèves et ça les aide un peu a pas
devoir se réveiller tous les matins en
disant ah qu'est ce que j'aime être
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui
dormait à l'illégalité de se propager
dans le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
dans une école anglaise je pense que
c'est important cela représentait près
dans une belle manière
[Musique]